joined by Charlotte Rose who organized
today's protest and by miles Jackman
who's an obscenity lawyer welcome to
both Sky News tonight Charlotte let's
start with you and unusual demonstration
why did you organize it um well when
when it came upon and Twitter of all the
the regulations had gone through you
know there was a bit of an uproar and
people were stating something needs to
be done about it and somebody tweeted me
and said this is a person that needs to
get on board in that I thought let's do
something about it well what has
happened in the law works the change in
the first of December so Monday last
week the AVMs regulations came into
force by way of a statutory instrument
what that means is that the law has
changed from video on demand services in
this country what can be shown is
regulated by the Association of
television on demand or whatever they're
calling themselves this week and they
have decided that certain activities
that are perfectly legal to perform and
legal under the obscene publications Act
should be verboten that's the point
because if you want to watch this stuff
I mean can you buy DVDs with their dog
no you can't not even for made abroad if
they made it well miles is the expert in
because the laws sided test yeah because
I think the government's argument is all
they're trying to do is to bring online
as it were streaming in line the deal is
the argument that those views so the DVD
laws date to 2000 after a high court
decision so we're only 15 years out of
date bringing that up to date with the
internet there's easy true that that's
what they're doing that's the excuse
that they're using social values around
sexuality have changed in the last 15
years I've conducted trials including
the porn trial and the obscenity trial
which has shown that certain activities
members of the public
absolutely not bothered about yet the
BBFC an app for decides that these
activities should be prohibited but this
is simply aligning really what's on DVDs
and what's online so why the issue in
some ways I mean you could argue this is
just the
of making things a bit more streamlined
sorry and in at the end of the day that
what this has done is this is affected
people in the sense that it's it's not
about what they've done they've done it
without consent so they're censoring us
without our consent in doing so so
basically they're saying that we are not
allowed to watch illegal activity in the
privacy of our own home I mean one of
the things is banking for example that
is Ramin what happens now if someone
were to break the law and watch
streaming of a bigger issue here is
actually censorship in the internet so
an unelected quango have declared trade
sanctions against foreign countries
trade so they have coerced banking
institutions to prohibit payments of UK
credit and debit card users from
purchasing material from above not
suppose they not they chose illegal
section or adjust the issue of
pornography yeah pornography is the
canary in the coal mine of free speech
if it dies other freedoms will fall in
other words this is not equating
watching these activities with child
pornography for example ooh I know they
say you have been regulate so you don't
make profit in Jesus Union material but
and this is about consensual adult
material viewed by adults yeah but what
I saw in the poverties aren't the same
at all is they know it's it's a
regulatory matter and therefore it's
about fining people so that fraud can
line their pockets oh then you've said
these laws frankly focus on the wrong
areas it doesn't really tackle things
like issues of consent and is that's a
big problem here it is indeed our prime
minister has voted against teaching
consent to younger women in schools and
is sending out a very mixed message
about sexual consent by prohibiting
sexual activities which are consensual
between adults and so certain
communities particularly female pleasure
LGBTQ BDSM etc are being
disproportionately told Charlie it's not
a one-day protest this is going on no
definitely not
I mean um
the public today has just been
absolutely amazing and passion sympathic
the people had today was fantastic and
it was amazing we are going to be doing
it again and you know this is just the
beginning at the end of the day nobody
has the right to censor us without our
consent
so we're kind of right back